[Music]
Tucker Carlson tonight congresswoman
Alexander Acacio Cortez lecturing us
about the weather again flash floods in
DC on Monday she said weren't an act of
God no they were the fault of
Republicans for not passing her green
new deal and giving her full power over
the American economy just one problem
with that though actual scientists
disagree with her read on that we'll
talk to one just ahead but first tonight
quick here's a quiz for you how many
foreign nationals are living in the
United States right now just kidding
that's a trick question nobody knows the
answer could be ten million could be
fifty million we just be guessing pretty
embarrassing for a supposedly advanced
country not to know who lives within its
borders but honestly we have no idea the
last two years the Trump administration
has been trying to fix that by including
a simple citizenship question on the
2020 census Democrats hate the idea of
course if voters actually knew how many
non-citizens lived in the United States
they might be less enthusiastic about
giving free health care to illegal
aliens so last month liberals on the
Supreme Court threw up roadblocks to
adding the citizenship question to the
census the Attorney General though this
week seemed confident it's gonna happen
anyway
watch we've been considering all the
options and I've been in constant
discussions with the president ever
since the Supreme Court decision came
down and I think over the next day or
two you'll see what approach we're
taking I think it does provide a pathway
for getting the question on the census a
large majority of Americans agree with
that so does the United Nations there's
nothing inherently weird or
controversial about asking if someone's
a citizen of a country every nation has
a right to know that ten previous
censuses in the United States have asked
about citizenship by the way including
the long-form census in 2000 that when
Bill Clinton was president that was less
than 20 years ago nobody at the time
claimed it was unconstitutional to ask
about citizenship because it was not
unconstitutional and it still is not the
Constitution hasn't changed what has
changed is the Democratic Party suddenly
they're telling us it's illegal for the
government to ask if you're a citizen or
not why
you know why the same reason they give
for objecting to everything it's racist
the citizenship question is motivated by
racial and partisan reasons it has no
business as something that's supposed to
be neutral almost boring this is
political motivation mr. this is very
racialized this is because you don't
want communities like mine being
represented here in this chamber equally
this is not about whether or not I want
to know who is a citizen in the United
States or not I want to know about the
racism that and the and the very
disturbing history that we're seeing
here that's what I want to know this is
about keeping you know make America you
know this hat make America white again
there's such liars
at some point words like these lose
their power and their meaning from
misuse it's utterly absurd of course but
it's also entirely fake like most of
their temper tantrums do what I want or
I'll call you a racist that's always
their threat how long people fall for it
how long the Republicans in Congress be
intimidated by it
there's nothing racial about a
citizenship question obviously the
question like that would apply to
everyone whether they're Honduran or
Norwegian or Congolese or Korean it
doesn't matter
it's literally colorblind not that
Democrats care the Democratic Party is
not interested in stopping racism what
they want is power shut up and obey
they're telling you don't ask questions
about what's happening to your country
you're not allowed to know